ya estamos familiarizados con la idea de
la división si tuviera que dividir 8
entre 2 podría pensar que son 8 objetos
así que 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 divididos en
grupos iguales de 2 cuántos grupos
iguales de 2 podrías tener bueno puedes
tener 1 2 3 y 4 grupos de 2 y entonces
dirías que 8 dividido entre 2 es igual a
4 otra forma en que podríamos haber
pensado es que tienes 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y
si tuvieras que dividirlo en dos grupos
iguales podrías tener un grupo de 4 y
luego un segundo grupo de 4 así que
tenemos dos grupos iguales cuántos
tienes en cada uno de esos grupos
iguales bueno son cuatro en cada uno de
esos grupos una vez más 8 dividido entre
2 es igual a 4
ahora vamos a ampliar nuestro
conocimiento sobre la división
comenzando a pensar en cosas que no se
dividen en partes iguales
entonces qué pasaría si tuviéramos que
dividir 8 entre 3 pausa este vídeo y
trata de pensar en eso un poco de
acuerdo dibujemos 8 objetos de nuevo 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 y una manera de pensar sobre
esto es podemos dividir esto en grupos
que tengan tres y cuántos grupos
podríamos hacer de tres bueno vamos a
intentarlo puedo hacer este grupo de
tres y este segundo grupo de tres pero
no puedo hacer más grupos de tres y me
quedan estos dos y una manera de
describirlo es que yo puedo hacer dos
grupos de tres por lo que esto es igual
a dos y quedan algunos queda un residuo
dejen de escribir este concepto
importante también hay un residuo de dos
y por lo tanto a veces se escribe como
una erre minúscula el residuo de dos
otra forma de pensar en esto es este dos
por tres y seis y luego si tuviera que
regresar el residuo podría llegar a 8
ahora otra forma de pensar en esto es
como lo vimos en el segundo ejemplo con
ocho divididos entre dos déjame dibujar
ocho objetos de nuevo uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y podrías
decir permítanme dividir
esos ocho en tres grupos iguales así que
pausa el vídeo y trata de dividirlo en
tres grupos iguales y calcular lo que
podría quedar como residuo muy bien
entonces voy a tratar de dividir esto en
tres grupos iguales no voy a poder poner
cuatro en cada uno de estos grupos
porque solo puedo hacer dos grupos de
cuatro no voy a poder poner tres en tres
grupos iguales ya que en realidad
necesitaría nueve para hacer eso así que
cada uno de mis grupos tendrá que ser de
dos entonces voy a hacer un grupo de dos
otro grupo de dos y ahí van tres grupos
iguales de dos así que pude hacer tres
grupos iguales de dos con estos seis
pero una vez más tengo un residuo no
puedo hacer uso de estos dos porque no
encajan en los tres grupos iguales si
fuera a hacer cuatro grupos iguales
entonces encajarían
como tengo tres grupos iguales porque
estoy dividiendo entre 3
me quedo con estos 2 otra vez hagamos un
ejemplo más qué pasaría si te pregunto
cuánto estrés he dividido entre 4 pausa
el vídeo y piénsalo como puedes imaginar
habrá un residuo involucrado muy bien
dibujemos 13 objetos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 y tratemos de dividir esto
en grupos iguales de 4 así que veamos
este es un grupo de 4 tengo un grupo de
4 este es otro grupo de 4 tengo dos
grupos de cuatro y luego este es otro
grupo de cuatro así que puedo encontrar
tres grupos iguales de cuatro por lo que
esto es igual a tres otra forma de
pensar en esto es que cuatro caben en
trece tres veces pero luego tengo este
pequeño círculo solitario me queda uno
tengo un residuo de 1 porque 4 por 3 es
igual a 12 pero si quieres llegar a 13
bueno entonces tienes este residuo aquí